today i'm going to talk about the big
reason why your arteries are calcifying
and potentially turning into bone
now since heart disease is the number
one killer worldwide i think it's
important
to discuss
a nutritional aspect
of this problem
that
gives you something you can do about it
and this video is primarily going to
talk about the calcium part of this
problem more than
cholesterol or other problems with the
heart what are the top warning signs
that someone can get with a heart attack
well number one you'd have chest pain
especially if you're exercising or
exerting yourself or going through
emotional stress
and the chest pain is relieved when you
rest that is a really good indicator
that there could be a heart problem and
then we have referred pain to your left
shoulder or arm okay or even your back
or the jaw
or this side of your head
since the heart is slightly on the left
side it can refer to that area right
here all right number three heartburn
without really having heartburn okay so
you could have just a burning feeling in
your chest
that has nothing to do with
acid
number four shortness of breath
especially
exercise or climbing stairs
and number five there is no symptoms you
just drop dead of a heart attack now the
big problem with calcium is the
hardening of the arteries
and now we lose the elasticity we don't
have the ability to adapt to
stress
blood pressure etc it just becomes
hardened and that puts a huge stress
on the entire body now what's
interesting about calcium in the
arteries is it's not passive
you just don't end up with calcium
in the arteries for no reason it's an
active thing that occurs in certain
conditions now as far as the type of
calcium in the arteries they are finding
that it's the
same type of calcium that is in your
bone hydroxyapatite in fact this type of
calcium makes up 70 of the calcium in
your bone and the vascular system
is the second most calcified tissue in
the body
uh excluding your bones okay now we do
know as people age
their body starts to calcify okay so
they start having calcium deposits in
their joints
of course in the arteries
in their eyes
in their tissues
all over and so this video that you're
watching is a very important video to
understand
the mechanism and what you can do about
it but we do want to keep the bones
calcified and we want to keep the other
tissues
not calcified now like i've already
mentioned we don't want our arteries
becoming bone
and a really good test to do to
determine if you have calcium in your
arteries is a cac score
stands for coronary artery calcification
score okay i had it done you want the
results to be zero no calcium in the
arteries that puts you at a very very
low risk of heart attacks and
mortality so the cac test is not only
one of the best
predictors
of whether or not you're going to have a
heart attack
it's also a really good predictor for
mortality in general because
calcification in your tissues
is a pathological sign that there's
something seriously wrong with your
health now the other point i want to
bring up is the majority of people over
six years old
have some type of calcium building up in
the arteries which again like i said it
should not be there now i want to cover
something about
bone tissue
in your bones you have two types of
cells you have the osteoblast and then
you have the osteoclast
and the osteoblasts are the bone cells
that are building bone okay they're
building bone up and they're creating
bone and then we have the osteoclast
which actually degrades or breaks down
bone so we have these two things
happening in the bone at all times right
so if you have too much of this you get
osteoporosis
and then if you have too much of this
in your arteries especially
you start getting calcification in your
bones your your arteries actually are
turning into bone which is just
it's just bizarre and if we're talking
about inside your arteries we're talking
about the
endothelium which is the inner
tissue
of your arteries there's actually stem
cells okay in this layer of your artery
that are osteogenic what does that mean
osteogenic it means that they're capable
of producing
bone and so a stem cell
is an undifferentiated cell it's kind of
like a blank slate that has the
potential to turn into
a certain cell depending on what the
body needs
so when someone starts developing bone
tissue in their arteries that is a big
problem
in the
differentiation of
what this stem cell should turn into now
if we take a look at autoimmune diseases
we have the same problem we have a
differentiation problem your immune
system is unable to differentiate
between a normal cell and a pathogen it
ends up attacking your own cells
and so with this problem it's very
similar it's a differentiation problem
well guess what
vitamin k2 is a vitamin
that was recently discovered now when i
say discovered i mean that it's been
there all this time we just did not
recognize it and vitamin k2 is involved
in this differentiation problem if you
have sufficient vitamin k2 in your body
you're going to inhibit this
calcification problem you're going to
inhibit the osteoblast the cell
that forms bone in the wrong
place
so vitamin k2 is a potent
stimulator
of a certain protein called matrix gela
protein and this protein inhibits
vascular mineralization
and is dependent on k2 so if you don't
have k2
this protein is not going to inhibit
vascular mineralization or calcification
vitamin k2 is becoming more and more
popular there's over 3 500
research papers on vitamin k2 that you
can look up and so vitamin k2 is all
about
keeping calcium out of the arteries and
keeping calcium in the bone and making
your bones very very strong now i
believe that the majority of the
population is deficient in vitamin k2 at
least subclinically okay and i'm going
to tell you why in the next section
all right why are we deficient in
vitamin k2
well what's interesting about k2 it's
made
by
bacteria okay it's different than
vitamin k1 which actually comes from
leafy greens and so vitamin k2 is made
by bacteria in fact even in your gut you
can convert vitamin k1 to k2 okay if you
have the right
microbes so
if you have
gut problems okay and you don't have the
right microbes you can't make this
conversion that's number one also as far
as an absorption problem vitamin k2 is a
fat soluble vitamin which means it's
dependent on bile okay which is produced
by the liver and if your liver is fatty
which
you can pretty much tell if you have a
fatty liver if you have a belly okay if
you have belly fat you have a fatty
liver the more damage to the liver the
less bile you're going to make and the
less k2 you're going to absorb if you
don't have a gallbladder if you have a
congested gallbladder if you have
gallbladder problems if you have a bile
deficiency you will also have a problem
absorbing vitamin k2 if you have
inflammation in your gut if you have
gastric bypass surgery or some type of
problem with your gut
that can inhibit your absorption of k
2.
also if you don't have enough fermented
foods you could be deficient in k2
because certain microbes in the
fermentation process can actually make
vitamin k2 so let me give you some
examples we have nato which is a
fermented soybeans i think it's very
popular
in the east um
not in the west
sauerkraut has k2 okay you know what
that is cheese is a fermented product
raw cheese especially if it's hard
cheeses or soft cheeses
from europe because usually they have
raw milk cheese you're going to have a
good amount of vitamin k2 if you
actually can get raw butter okay and
grass-fed butter you have a good amount
of vitamin k2 and guess what butter is a
fermented
product okay
and then of course we have kefir which
is
one level above yogurt if that's made
from grass-fed animals you're going to
have a good amount of k2 of course if
you're getting conventional yogurt or
conventional kefir
that is pasteurized and sweetened you're
probably not going to get very much k2
now vitamin k2 is also in
egg yolks it's also in
beef liver especially if it's grass-fed
it's in
sausage it's basically in fatty foods so
if you're on a low-fat diet okay
you might be omitting these right here
and what's really bizarre to me is take
a while guess what mainstream recommends
for cardiovascular
disease okay if you guessed a low-fat
diet you are correct what do they
recommend they recommend fruits
vegetables
grains at least half whole grains and
half refined grains and they even allow
a good amount of added sugars to that
diet and so this is just another one of
those examples of finding out what
they are telling you to do or what
mainstream is telling you to do and do
the complete opposite
i mean even take a look at statin drugs
right
satin drugs inhibit vitamin k2
and i'll put a research paper down below
to back that up now as far as the type
of vitamin k2 there's a lot of different
types
one type in these foods right here is
mk4 but if you get mk4 and supplement
they make it synthetically i recommend
the natural form of vitamin k2 which is
mk7
and i also recommend taking it with
vitamin d okay now as far as the ratios
go if you're taking 10 000 ius of
vitamin d3 you would take 100 micrograms
of vitamin k2
one last point about vitamin d that's
actually quite interesting some people
are concerned about the toxicity levels
of
vitamin d3 right well really the only
side effect from taking very large
amounts of vitamin d3 i'm talking like
several hundred thousand ius of vitamin
d3 over a month okay
the only
major complication
is hypercalcemia
that means
too much calcium in the blood well guess
what vitamin k2 does it helps to keep
the calcium out of the arteries and in
the bone that's why i recommend taking
them together and on that note i think
you might find it interesting
in this next video on vitamin d toxicity
check it out